[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
when we talk about whatever we want
mm-hmm this another intro - yep every
time you know that's all bad intro yes
it's a civil war music it's that [ __ ]
breakbeat song oh yeah yeah they just
made a remake of it I don't know no I
don't know anyway all right I'll play it
for you later I'll play for you later
right yeah Egyptian lover
eat gyptian lover mind melt yeah so gia
this morning it tasted blood huh uh no I
didn't taste it per se okay this girl's
think she's so cool now I did it's so
funny she said G all right did we do I
know who you are
he's my ste now do you see this dude
she's standing up to her bloody money
give women rights and look what happens
me too bro that's what I'm saying right
now I'm telling you to sock me in the
face for two years now just do it just
hurry up I think it's because you want
me to do it so I'm not gonna do it I
don't want you to hit me in the face
then watch it's gonna happen wait for it
so you may Bart's nosebleed I did
so um bartson pushed me to do the Mart
mixed martial arts stuff that you guys
do in the morning I was like [ __ ] it I
want to do it so then I started training
and then I got him with a right hook
I was nice that's a cow blood came out
oh my god I'm so sorry my nose is
[ __ ] awesome are you smiling
yeah smiling his pants started to slowly
rise you say you trying to [ __ ] right
now with blood in his teeth the first
time I saw that oh wow that's crazy it's
like I see you sex yeah yeah taking your
an I see you I'm trying here
I see P in st. cloud shape are you
talking about did you get it right hook
to the face - yeah I think polyp eyes
yeah turns you on sometimes it sounds a
little blood a leak out of there and
then a girl comes over and she's trying
to share your you know your oxygen tone
and you just probably what are your
buddies in keeping that you keeping you
alive well you haven't said then you
take your syringe out you put it in her
arms a little bit bro get your life
together man how do we sound more
trouble than us
reevaluate yourself given the Bermuda
Mexican triangle right now no clue what
ethnicity anybody in this room that's a
crazy part there at first I thought
everybody was Mexican and then now I'm
not sure and then I thought everybody
was Vietnamese
no I don't know he's Mexican Mexican
just lying why would you tell him I oh I
would have gotten two out of five
really yeah right I would have guessed
um Korean are you Korean I'm Chinese
okay sorry why shouldn't one percent
Korean there you go one percent right
Middle Eastern yeah Middle Eastern but
yeah like something also happened and
like your family's not telling you
everything I would have thought maybe
from New York guy you know pizza guy and
then I'm not sure Louisiana dude I'm
really bad I'm polish Nicaraguan so Oh
somebody [ __ ] on a boat you know like
um that's that rare myth what were you
raised that um I was raised just as
white pretty much when people call us
Mexicans they call your family Mexican
yeah but even with like your thick ass
accent they would still call you like
Mexican yeah because we my brother had
like we had like the darkest skin in
town my brother had like really dark
skin and so yeah they were like all you
guys are Mexicans you know yeah I spoke
some Spanish when I was young we don't
speak that much anymore
did your mom were dead Nicaragua dad so
he's he's a mustache yeah but he was 70
when I was born my dad was old his old
man he was kind of cute hat but with no
money and his robe was always open he
was I let me do the other part
hypnotized Holloway that's like if I did
well part of uh Louisiana did you go
just like in the like in the middle of
nowhere kind of just like a rural area
you know so it's pretty chill dudeee a
lot of animals you know you should sell
hamsters growing up one of my first jobs
that's yeah I grew up in a breeding area
like I had a lot of breeding breeders by
us I did hamsters and uh gpa's guinea
pigs
did you sell GP that's like a gangster
if you never said guinea pigs I thought
that was some hood ass pigs my baby just
come up you couldn't walk into their
front porch without the pig coming out
pigs have like the littlest arms did you
sell them on like a little red wagon he
was dragging a red light everywhere no
we had like a group this man like
imported and exported him so he was
running big numbers of them and then we
used to sell them outside of raves bras
crazy
you buy them every time three dollars
five dollars browse outside of yet crazy
concert hall and oates Leonard Skynyrd
we get out there and sell them man cuz
people all next to see people on that
dust and we [ __ ] telling them hey
let's get rid of these genius dude
well we sold a bunch and then people
started telling Barabbas and that put us
on to put us out this is like the
wildest thing to us but this is just
your everyday life though you talked
about it and it's like you're like
you're [ __ ] multi-million dollar
business what ha ha ha ha
well I was working man I wasn't working
that was my first job Pablo Escobar I'm
a musician you know you know what the
craziest rodent King ya know a friend
who was born and they were born and
raised in Louisiana they said like
there's a lot of like weird exotic
animals out in Louisiana cuz a lot of
importers are out there and they just
have crazy like illegal animals yes my
buddy had a monkey at his house that
could our little monkey that could roll
a [ __ ] pack of the tack of marijuana
bull yeah I don't remember I wasn't
smoking there yeah I was a smoking yes
uh I don't know ah didn't get a real no
the monkey didn't smoke he falls asleep
on the branch with this bud he's holding
the joint but there's a lot of people
yes just cuz it's a you know people are
in the rural areas they got more animals
you could have them easier without
people calling the cops on your stuff so
you might have a friend with a wild
animal but anyhow what were you talking
about
nothing random [ __ ] this is a random
segment oh well then it's perfect yeah
it's a get to know feel segment no I
don't smoke I used to smoke yeah dude
because your story's so funny and then
your shirt has the Eifel town with a
drop on it actually a child picture so
it's a yeah this is a ice cream parlor
in our town
yeah really no that'd be so great though
your stories with the HAMP's and the
freaking G pigs I don't know there's
like slang words were edition this is a
street name for a rabbit
oh shoot same bits but I don't think so
I didn't see any of that I wasn't in
there yeah my buddy had like these
little like he had all these cages and
stuff and then he had this outdoor place
for all the hamsters and guinea pigs
would be and it was literally like these
little bitty fences that they built
and they would just have like 400 of
them over no they're so stupid yeah well
someone would try to get on each other's
backs you know and that's my buddy was
sit there and he would kind of put him
back in you know he was like a [ __ ]
Shepherd yeah I guess he was like a chef
guinea pigs actually live a pretty long
life don't but they're beautiful animals
yeah
but they eat them in Peru or something
in like South America they ate him like
their [ __ ] breakfast like just a
breakfast or some [ __ ] Kiki's parents
ate some and it was prepared different
ways and they were like okay they don't
like it it's like a havin pheasant or
something it's basically just like a
ground bird almost it's almost like it's
just like a bird that's on the ground if
you ever had dove or pheasant that dove
dude yeah a couple brothers used to live
by me when I was growing up and they
were always grilling dove outside like
from hunting and or they just kept it's
called a dove and and I'd never ate it
for years and then one time I was like
our I don't have some you know it was
all right it's like being in one of
those places like almost like you know
what dove is right is squab you don't
want to have any fancy restaurants like
french fry sauce squab pigeon
you know it's pigeon pigeon do yeah you
can squab is pigeon yeah but it's not
street pigeon it could be the like you
matter yeah it's like pigeon from like
New York or something
it's farm pigeon it tastes like you
shouldn't be you know like it tastes
like it's not really yes something for
you you know it tastes like it wishes it
like you weren't eating it
are you an adventurous eater like you're
not that much crazy [ __ ] no not that
much really anymore I think what I was
younger I was but now I want to stay
alive and everything you know not like
this guy was [ __ ] ingesting whatever
and just growing you know I don't give a
[ __ ] see what happens after this ticket
is a straight-up test animal over here
beautiful gives me give it to me things
it give to me
yeah so you recently found out you got
scabies right no and I scabies girl god
yeah
missa right it's not a pirate
yeah psoriasis yeah I guess like yellow
he got plague right it's so funny like
hot dog got Lyme disease that everybody
has to like me
it's just psoriasis I'm like okay cool
and this is something like out like pity
me psoriasis ten days it'll be gone
there's no big get sexually
transmittable or not nice this is you
have it or you don't it's not it's not
like like everyone hasn't it but it is
dormant yeah Rose it dormant or not like
allergies
it's basically allergies that's this
[ __ ] we're trying to get to the bottom
tell us your [ __ ] May you're not really
saying it's just allergies basically
serious just annoy some people get it
really bad so like I have a very mild
form of it so what the [ __ ] you can you
get never mind but that looks crazy to
be my diseases of brother looks kind of
wish out dying and then he just told me
Oh psoriasis told me to go home and stop
being a [ __ ] but yeah I guess like most
people get it on their scalp and [ __ ] so
you know they'll have like bad dandruff
and [ __ ] yeah so mine is supermodel I
see you seen that [ __ ] I've seen this
guy's back of the head that [ __ ] looked
like a [ __ ] nasty ass oh it was I
wanted to [ __ ] get a knife and scalp
him that's all that we saw in Orlando
like on there it was kind of like that
but it was like imagine um imagine like
a UH like a nipple like a bunch of
little [ __ ] nipples just popping out
was like I want to [ __ ] scratch it
off it was he also on the larger side no
okay but it he was at our meet and greet
actually and when he turned around I saw
his [ __ ] neck right there anymore
that's but you know what happens though
stop that [ __ ] so if you scratch
a lot of people scratchy kitschy but
then it's not as bad as mosquito bite
some pretty fine so when I say mind yes
that's really mild yeah so a lot of
people scratching it'll get [ __ ] up to
die or don't die guy you know this
disease is getting kind of chatty with
this disease if I can figure it out at
this point man you can't back in suraíh
see stuff did you just wake up and it
was everywhere yeah I just woke up and
was in full-blown or do you just see it
slowly growing with like one like area
and then six hours later it just
ballooned and I was like you scratch it
or not know is it itchy
not save [ __ ] do you think that I mean
because some chicks love a man that's
like always injured is love that [ __ ]
back to hell
ya know this is doctor I mean that's
like girls that gay with the bad boy cuz
you know she wants to fix up he's a
broken heart broke I wanna get what's a
sick boy I'm a basic ass [ __ ] then you
don't like it I'll you'd like a healthy
man yeah sure but you broke his deal
mister day he's donating blood earlier
it turns him on I wanted to give him a
boner thank ya blood boners that's a new
sex tape yeah come in coming your way
soon folks it's like it's like eczema
yeah I got that on my it's kind of gone
now yeah he's got his under control man
you got it hey are you pimping your
diseases are not broken your stuffs
getting out of the way this man like
it's got a funny reason check here so
[ __ ] funny look that trig bro
within this group I have like the worst
luck and so I'm so I'm so used to it
then when [ __ ] happens I woke up I was
like so another thing would you join me
yesterday I told you I'm like David god
[ __ ] you sir I know well we started
laughing it's so funny cause like the
doctor's like what else happened I was
like well I came for the torn meniscus
he goes we do you know I just live
[ __ ] Bear Grylls or so she literally
winds me fall down like a flight of
stairs for no reason we were on like a
little barely Grylls bro anything is
still getting [ __ ] whole life is like
[ __ ] you know that one movie where
you're supposed to die and [ __ ] what's
it called final destination right but
the guy just can't get like he just
keeps missing me yeah he's like pissed
off right now he was like 12 car
collisions right behind all the time oh
the guy upset she's just getting [ __ ]
frustrated he's like come on Jesus to
Sunday
people if you're trying to kill him you
got it you got to succeed you know you
guys got to step your game up
yeah yeah close call I'm still here man
Dave is still here that should be you
should get that tattooed on Oh
David still here and then I'll get it
like hell [ __ ] it blood disease from the
tattoo but I still live it's like I'm
still here [ __ ] dude in like a couple
years you have no arms no legs no head
bro I'm just a jaw dentist and the
distance is waiting to this point deep
out I'm still here no you can't kill him
it's tough need tougher diseases man no
Isaac recently has been super sick he
sick he missed two days at school no
like well I food poisoning
no you stepdad my son oh he was two days
of school he was yeah he was he dropped
out or you couldn't keep going or
something but um that's unfortunate how
old your son he's 10 what is he got the
the scabies babies no no he has he has a
fever like a major fever and he also
it's a really bad cough what is it at
like 102 103 yeah he had like 102 damn
for how many days for two days
and it was so crazy cuz um he he
recently did that performance so he
plays Pete a violin mm-hmm a dirty
violin or something dirty or maybe maybe
that's where you got I don't know his
classmates I feel like it's something
that's going around but he had this
performance and he that's when he was
already feeling like starting to feel
bad he didn't really tell us that day
because he really wanted to go through
with his performance such a opposite of
look why don't wear his suit so bad like
he was not required to wear a suit all
he had to do is just wear a white shirt
like a dressy shirt and that's it he's
like no mommy I really have to worry my
suit something like all right I wanted
to show up yeah we forgot to give it to
him in the morning and so we ended up
having to go we picked him up after
school and then gave him his his uh well
not after school it was like before the
performance we gave him his suit and he
was like so happy and he had a suit but
then I looked at him and he looked like
his eyes are really droopy you're just
like you came up to me
well you're not having dinner the
opposite I told him like let's go you
don't have to do it it's okay he's like
no mommy I'm gonna get a bad grade I
don't want a minute mommy
I'm Chinese now I need to do this
daddy's Chinese so I gotta do anything
there's a girl that he likes and he's
trying to show off you know I'll put on
my [ __ ] suit was he like flicking
tongue as he was looking on the crop via
live or die you [ __ ] moment exondia
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't care that was way
taller than him and she was blocking him
the whole I would like barred a attack
you gotta hit her with that little
violin handle you know the whole time I
was just trying to film him and I was
just little girls move I can't see him
some Tim Duncan broad is in front of him
the whole time oh this sweetie sound
like a sound like a sound like a like a
nice boy
[Laughter]
he had all these disses but he doesn't
wanna hurt her feelings
unit sounds a gun yeah I thought he was
gonna drop some knowledge yeah I didn't
have any legend I'm kind of a you know
train was late brother the train is late
I just picture your you getting like
hella mad at your brain right now just
like come on free the [ __ ] up you're
embarrassing me when I got a fever when
I was a kid it felt like so much hotter
than it does it as an adult like you
know I'm talking about like oh you a kid
you got high you're like holy [ __ ] no
but I love getting sick though
even though I was in pain I [ __ ]
loved it because then I could stay home
and watch TV and anything so weird like
when a guy gets sick and then like your
girlfriend gets sick or your wife or
whatever because girls like handle their
[ __ ] they'll be sick I got a lot of
going online like reaching for the water
can you please don't [ __ ] you pick up
the kid they're sick they'll still go to
work yeah I just can't handle that [ __ ]
dude like that's like my or she's right
next to me and like what my assistant
she doesn't for anymore buzz like can
you test my orange juice
she lived like the mission goes oh my
[ __ ] god every time I think it's it
Casey always get sick cause he has like
a really bad immune system so right now
in Casey's like staying away from him
he's like don't come near me Isaac like
I don't want to get him good morning
daddy [ __ ] you thank you think no go
away and then I saw like I'm like you
know how you get big don't get it's a
pound that emergency yeah get him in the
gym dude her giving us suppositories
dude those were always crazy bro don't
want me to put like four suppositories
in my butt and send me to school yeah no
but yeah that's where they got it you
can't orally take them dude what the
[ __ ] is a positive yes he'll for your
butt it's like the fastest way forward
to a blue with your body not hurt about
it you can do it protein powder - dude
I'm sure you can but vert you better
straighten your butt you're lying you're
lying
I don't believe you oh you definitely
can't this it's called boo thing I think
where they yeah somebody blow coaching
bow every time you say [ __ ] that blows
my mind I just want Louisiana
go ahead they're right hahaha do we have
the only Vietnamese uh House of
Representatives congressman there's hell
of enemies people who yeah cuz they got
all the shrimp boats right he's not
getting these bro
but dude no but everybody thinks you a
friend from Louisiana is good even
though yeah yeah everybody thinks you're
like a wrestler in Vietnam dude when I
was in Japan I type out over everybody
like even in their subways they have
like their handles right that [ __ ] was
right here for me my chest felt like
swing like this
here's fixing people's hair patting
people you're petting a whole family
[Laughter]
[Music]